Hello.
I think that did it. Yeah, that did it.
Perfect.
Uh, and no delay as well. Like no delay
at all. Okay, that's nice.
Um,
let me make sure the t the category is
set. I really wish you could set a
default category,
but we're good for now.
So,
uh, the cool thing,
well, not really the cool thing. Um, one
minor administrative thing, I just set
up, uh, I just finally like bothered
registering for Twitch affiliate.
And the main reason I did that is if you
don't have like the Twitch turbo
whatever thing um the subs disable ads
fully. I actually I tried to reduce the
ads to only be 30 seconds an hour which
is the minimum. But if I do that then
you get pre-roll ads. So I left it on 3
minutes an hour uh which is the minimum
to not have pre-roll ads. And then I the
sub disables ads.
Best I can do. But I also figured maybe
it gives lower latency or whatever. I
don't know.
Anyways,
hello folks. Me make sure my chat still
works.
It does. And Twitch, at least when I
started up the stream, we'll see if it
drifts, but it's like basically zero
latency today. I messed with some
settings. I was on like some weird
network connections. We should be good.
Okay,
so
uh here is the deal now. All right,
here's the deal.
We have actually let's just show this
real quick.
We have
about 11,000 lines of code total here.
And I'd really like to start getting
towards something that is official
releasable. You know, I'd like this to
be close to what we can release
officially.
Uh, in order to do that, it's just going
to take quite a bit of time of me going
through little bit by little bit.
In my mind, this is one of the actually
most valuable things I do. Even though
it is quite slow, I'll try to keep it
entertaining. Um, but I figure I will
chip away at it a little bit today
because I'm in a good mood to refactor
some stuff. You can see I've moved some
things around in here. Hey, convert
very nice. If you have like good tests,
we definitely need more of them,
especially selfplays.
I cleaned up the top chunk of this. I'm
still not entirely sure
we want the Kublas rappers like this.
Right. I was going to actually try to
think about
our tensor names, wasn't I?
Even though naming is much more minor,
it is slightly more productive for me to
do it earlier.
Okay, they just have tensor
legacy C. They literally did the same
thing, didn't they?
Indra
So, this actually does match the old
torch C, which is probably why I have
it.
all convert. Yeah, it's Well, that's the
thing. They're all
They're all essentially interchangeable,
except I've been enjoying this a lot
just because this model is much faster.
Hey Nesh,
welcome.
I like this. I think that is the C99. I
think that's a more modern thing, isn't
it?
Even like stupid things like this
actually does matter.
I mean, I'm going to be honest. Like,
the main reason I don't like this is cuz
it looks like [ __ ] rust.
No, that's not really it. It's cuz then
you also you have to change stuff from
the default types,
right?
No, it isn't standard to be fair.
That's just That isn't standard. Okay.
Any fun update?
Uh, have you seen this?
Solved.
Okay. Bad seed.
Probably this is better
really.
Okay, there you go. Little bit of seed
inconsistency,
but we do get sub 1 second solves.
Buffer's fast, my guy.
Got to keep up.
Hey, Kvert.
That's when I saw your comment.
Uh 5C branch in is already pretty
stable. I am refactoring quite a bit
still, but it's mostly local changes.
I mean it's a simple end if we just use
it as a very fast test right this is our
agent playing it on the website
we have much more complex stuff on here
as well
lower no um what do you mean did I get
lower that's just from the sweep
What even is it? Yeah. 4 by32.
This is just a thing that the sweep
found, man.
The thing that's funny about this is
this is still got to be pure membound,
right? This has got to be like zero MFU.
I do wonder, do we name Collide if we
just do like
I don't know what we call per like the
precision type.
still solves.
Yeah. So, um you don't have async
though, right?
This is our new async trainer, man.
So like decent GPU env but then also the
async trainer adds a
What do we call this guys? What do we
call the data type that we use like the
variable type.
uh async just overlaps the end of an
inference compute with the training
compute at the cost of being one epoch
stale. You can read about it in Cleanba
if you just Google Costa Cleanba. It's a
very nice I mean that's exactly where I
got it from. It's nothing new.
I mean, everything is going to be much
shorter.
Like look, you see immediately this will
be a two liner instead of a threeliner.
This is going to be a twoliner instead
of a
Oops.
Uh that's weird that we have this like
that, but whatever.
Like you see
this is why I wanted to do this now.
Hello. Welcome. Still accepting M's?
Uh, we're definitely accepting M's.
Whether or not they should go to four or
five like is kind of whatever.
It's easier if you just PR him to 5C,
but um, you know, not big deal.
Teranova.
I don't know what that is.
Mini grid.
You definitely don't want to use the
mini grid from Farama along with Puffer
because that end will be like 100th of
the speed that Puffer can have if you're
lucky.
Um, that would just be like a quick port
whatever tasks you care about type
thing.
Like I hate to tell people the vibe code
stuff, but like that Env is so simple
that you could get that thing like
bitwise equivalent in probably 20
minutes out of any model.
But most of those tasks just would get
like Puffer will kind of just steamroll
most of those anyways. Just like there
won't be a research thing to do. It'll
just sort of be solved out of the box,
you know.
Teranova paper.
Let me see what this is.
Oh, wait. I think I know it. Let me see
if I think I know what this thing is. If
it's the new thing that I'm thinking of,
it's dumb.
Oh no. This is just not what I'm
thinking of. Okay, that's actually
[ __ ] cool. What the hell is this?
Wrong. This is actually cooperation is
strategically dominant.
This is also like not
Oh, this is not a good thing at like h I
hate academic papers so [ __ ] much
sometimes.
So, when they say the action space is
big, is it like big in the sense of
like, yeah, this is reasonable, or just
like, yeah, this is a massive pain in
the ass for no reason?
This is like mini civ, right?
Oh, it's J.
Is it J?
I'm guessing it's vibe coded jacks as
well, right?
Can you go figure out if it's anything
and if it's vi? Like we already have one
major project attempting to port craft
decks to Jax. So if it's like an
actually good and interesting end of
then sure. I'm just so [snorts] sick of
dealing with Jax.
Like the amount of brain damage that
that entire
view of computing has caused is nuts to
me.
And then of course Jax is hard so people
just start vibe coding it.
So, the annoying thing to be clear about
having to port um Jax to C is you don't
just do a onetoone port because Jax
forces you to write awful awful code. Um
you have to redesign quite a bit of
stuff to get it into nice efficiency
and it ultimately ends up being simpler
than the jacks,
but it's just a bit of a pain.
Okay, this is definitely not
worth clang formatting.
thing and I find it
your encoding. Wait
any I'm not quite sure how to interpret
that that question.
I am a researcher and I stream um
like engineering on our latest projects,
algorithmic research, various different
types of development.
Yeah, we're going to be able to delete
just like a lot of the
a lot of the random new line continues.
Can you split
Can you multi-line a um
a kernel launch?
Well, I think we're just going to end up
renaming that anyways.
Okay.
I'm just cleaning up little bits of
things here and there.
Like I'd already gone through, to be
clear, I'd already gone through this
this morning and then I just figured,
okay, I may as well do some of the
rename sooner rather than later because
otherwise I'm going to spend time
cleaning up the um the call signatures
and then the width of everything is
going to shift a whole bunch. Right.
Like this.
Uh, this one's actually this one can
stay
I see this like const like this
restrict.
It's just the cuda types being annoying.
Just the cuda types being annoying
realistically.
That's still fine though.
Yeah, that's still fine.
We'll fix the rest of the sigs
and then we'll go back up to around uh
thereish.
Well, actually, I think that it is time
to go from
like
Yeah, let's let's go from here. So,
I've gone over this decoder stuff quite
a bit
except for like occasionally LLM
slipping [ __ ] like that through. I
think I'm generally pretty happy with
this code.
I'm generally pretty happy with this
code.
It's quite a lot, but it's actually
fairly simple.
It's Yeah, it's actually very simple if
you look at it.
Okay, so
Okay, good.
This is done.
Still have the async stuff to look at,
but
And then basically this gets us down to
Muan,
which barring any major improvements to
the structure of our networks,
I think is good.
AI assisted. No idea what good jacks.
That's the thing. There isn't good
jacks. Um it's like a fundamentally
stupid programming paradigm.
Is this Oh, Edinburg. Okay.
Yeah, they have decent people sometimes.
I don't know. If somebody feels like
doing a uh a quick C port of it, by all
means,
just like
it has to actually be something
reasonable. If you're going to like just
write one prompt and be like, "Oh, okay.
It's done." Even though the code sucks.
I I don't want to deal with that.
One moment. I will be right back. I got
to check one thing.
Yeah. The problem with Jax is like it's
it's this really weird immutable
functional crap paradigm. And that's not
how computer works,
particularly not with Sims.
Well, yeah, you'll get an ML job at
Google. Is that like
I mean,
if that's what you if that's something
that is appealing to you, by all means.
One of the funny discoveries that you uh
you end up making is
like none of these big companies have on
average good people
at all.
And also being top two percentile at
jacks like
so being good at expressing operations
in their shitty Python DSL like
brain damage my guy.
Nobody says like, "Oh, get really good
at torch, right? It's such a Google bro
thing."
Okay, Kvert. But at least that's like an
honest like motive or whatever.
Sure. Cool.
What's this exactly? It's just like
Google brain damage.
Why do we have three kernels for this?
Let me see.
We have so many colonels for Muan. Let
me see.
Yeah. Why do we have so many of these
colonels?
We're just calling them one after
another
with arguably the same
Okay, it is a reduction. It's like an
annoying reduction pattern, I guess.
Let me see if I like this more.
Hey Tim.
Um, so if since it's been a while,
Puffer 6 and Puffer 5 essentially got
switched.
So we're doing like full native CUD to C
training pipeline plus speed
improvements before we're doing ALGO
stuff, but we did manage to sneak async
training in. we have some really fast
results and the code's going to be much
more compact and very clean and no
Python crap in the middle. Um,
but I didn't get to really fully explore
the state set stuff I wanted
I got to do one thing on the side here
for client.
Have to add somebody to a GitHub repo
real quick.
Why are hang on let me see
why are muons being mentioned no so muon
is also the name of um an optimization
algorithm
it's a successor or it's an improvement
for the most part over at Um,
okay. It's actually faster,
which is expected.
Very
Is it really faster to have a like
see this is me just not knowing enough
CUDA yet. Is it really faster to have a
uh a separate
Oh, this might be because we need to do
Um um
I think it is. I think you do. I think
that is standard.
So partials reduce and then you get the
netor.
Wait, hang on.
wait.
Partials reduce.
do we still have?
Let me remember this. I wrote this a
while ago.
Okay, so it's porm
and then there are many ways that you
can do this up
This updates momentum.
Wait, so this is norm partials and
gradorm. Okay, so we're using this on
different stuff. Cool.
and I'm trying to figure out why I need
to add somebody to a repo and I can't
figure out why it doesn't Take
and I think that's not on us that we
don't have access to the thing. So, I
can keep going for now.
Okay, I think we'll take I think we'll
accept that this is
Well, should we accept that this is
fine? I don't know.
It's just not trying to atomic add [ __ ]
Um,
this is just a simple block sum, isn't
it?
Maybe there's a way to restructure this
a little.
Add respect for the grind. It's honestly
not that big of a grind lately.
No, I have some uh there definitely
times where I'm just not putting in as
many hours.
Just the consistency long term that
really matters.
Hang on. This is
update pointer equals
scale equals
Okay. No. So, I need to do
the weight update needs to get applied
unconditionally.
And this is just what like
biases,
embeddings. things.
I I swear an LLM screwed this up at some
point without me look without me
noticing.
Hover five is coming along very well.
Major changes.
Net hack is gigasoded.
The necktac policy is awesome.
Finn is slightly away this week.
Binn's uh interning with us.
He's been doing great work.
How do interns get accepted?
Um, in the case of Finn, he submitted me
the best PR I've ever received and then
continued iterating on it for several
months and then he asked me for an
internship, so I couldn't say no,
obviously.
And he's been kicking ass as well.
Like look at this.
They did this in the first week just
cleaning up the drone and
I mean, it's ridiculous, right? Like,
look, same policy. Perfect hover.
Same policy to a cube.
Same policy to the American flag.
Hover
race.
Right.
So pretty much we don't have uh we don't
really take interns unless you do this
and then it's like yeah okay
Hang on. Aren't we losing something
here?
That's That's not old Arch. That's like
yesterday.
Oh, I guess a couple days ago at this.
Yeah. Um that's in progress. Ben's doing
that.
Wait. So, we have this GR. I'm so
confused here. Hang on. We have this
gram.
Okay, hang on. There does have to be a
buffer because
does there be does there have to be a
buffer?
Did I actually do it this way? I guess I
must have.
This is annoying because I don't trust
I don't trust Grock to be able to do
this.
Um, it's it's like a it's like one minor
version behind the other models, but
it's way faster.
Like the other models feel awful to use
because they will just spin for an hour
and they like completely take you out of
the loop.
Um, they have this like fast mode, but
it's not for the latest models
what I've seen.
Also, they just like it's ludicrously
expensive.
I'll let this spin a second and uh I'll
figure this out. Let me use a restroom
real quick and grab a drink.
Let's see.
I did already spend quite a bit of time
on this path, so it's quite possible
that this is better.
need diffuse the uh the constant in I
guess
It does seem silly that I don't have um
single update though.
It's just doing using the buffers such
that you end on um you end with them in
the correct one.
Now mind you, you can't change this
iteration number without breaking it,
but that's totally fine.
And this is also
it's like a pretty nice setup honestly.
>> It's funny. I almost didn't see this,
man.
Cuz there was too much nesting. I almost
didn't see that this was messed up.
same purpose before.
What's a clean up?
A little clean up.
I mean, that feels better as well to me,
having it this way. I was pretty proud
that I'd come up with that before. The
fact that LM just decided to break it
for no reason is [ __ ] So,
it's good.
One, two, three, four.
Uh,
Okay, but it replaced a previous one.
That's fine.
This
don't need to add more space. We already
have curlies.
It's like this. Don't even save any code
to remove that feature. It's fine. Just
leave it.
I really wish we could get this changed,
but
hang on. Offset plus equals
I think we can.
If that works, I'm happy.
It's funny how happy I get over saving
an indent level sometimes,
but in my mind, this just is so much
easier to follow.
Yeah, that's much easier to follow.
Okay, I'm genuinely a lot happier with
that.
I think anything else is pretty minor
Huh?
be a way to clean this up. Might not. I
think that this is pretty good though.
We may or may not care that much about
pryo because it's likely that this thing
gets deleted in puffer
What exactly use puffer in real world?
Two or three examples.
Sure.
A few things we've done.
This driving sim is used professionally
by multiple companies in uh autonomous
driving. This is a collab with NYU. We
made their thing 15x faster. We could
probably make it another 10x faster with
some work if we upgraded it to our
latest code.
Derivatives of this drone sim have been
used professionally,
so the details of that are confidential.
um
have these that I can show. Uh the
archive sim which is open source is used
in commerce.
We've also done work professionally in
finance and gaming.
On the research side, Huffer is becoming
increasingly widely used and it's
multiple orders of magnitude faster than
everything else out there.
It has led to the development of
multiple major algorithmic upgrades
to RL
as well as to getting dozens if not
hundreds of new people into the field
because all of a sudden you can run
experiments basically instantly without
having to have Google scale compute.
practical project on this channel. I've
done several
I mean I've streamed work on several
projects including one or two
professionally.
But like the point of this channel is
like I just do the dev that needs to be
done on Puffer Live.
I put out educational resources and some
of the stuff I do is educational, but
the priority is building the library and
doing the research.
But right now, for instance, this is me
working on improving the code quality
and refactoring
for the next release, the release of
Puffer 5.
Um, this is inherently like pretty slow
work. It is actually very informative if
you're looking just for like how to
write better code overall. And um,
it's I'd say actually one of my more
valuable skills. It does require a lot
of patience though.
You know, once I'm done with this, we
have research on selfplay. I streamed
some of this a few weeks ago. There was
an end that I was working on live with
Robocode like week or two ago.
I really really do want to get into
scientific sim, but in my mind it's like
the field needs to be, if not solved, at
least consistent, stable, and mature.
We're very close to that. It's it's
within the year. Well, not the calendar
year. It's less than a year away from
now, though.
It's nice.
We didn't break determinism.
That's good.
Open review rebuttal is so lame.
Welcome to academic publishing. There's
a reason I no longer do it.
at that.
Save us a line.
A few different little places probably.
Uh, this one's fine.
Is it
Yeah, exactly. Adrian, I really am not a
fan of the current direction
that uh scientific research
is taken, especially now.
I actually I just don't think academia
optimizes for the right things anymore.
And if you like if you want to do
something that actually solves problems,
you're kind of better off just focusing
on solving the problems than like
pleasing reviewers.
And um I have no idea what you just
said.
This is just a ton
of annoying kernels.
I don't know how much I care about this.
Hang on. 1354
That's 200 lines of code, man.
Plus the Alex.
Okay,
we've got a norm. We've got a reduce.
Got importance weights.
There are tons of helpful people in the
Discord solving lots of different
problems.
a lot of hobbyists kind of just learning
the ropes, but then there also several
people working on some harder Thanks.
CD CFD.
Oh
yeah, I don't know on that one. Convert.
It's powerful tech. Like there are going
to be a lot of things you can solve in
sim,
but I'm not going to go around like once
I start doing that, I'm not going to
just go around trying to solve every
problem with puffer, right? I figure
that this tech is powerful enough that
they're going to be a lot of obvious
standout problems once I start looking
for them. I'm not really going to get
attached to solving like any particular
problem as much as it's going to be, you
know, what stuff in science can we
really shift.
And if that sounds vague, like it is,
but it doesn't really matter because
it's just a big enough upgrade to
generic sim tech that obviously it will
have applications.
The reasoning doesn't really even have
to go much deeper than that.
it depends, Adrian.
When I'm writing code, like when I'm
fully writing code by hand,
I would say the design usually doesn't
change that much from my original.
That's because my designs tend to be
very simple
and um they're kind of efficient by
default like everything static memory
obs type set up to be as small as they
can
hashing things that obviously should be
cached
when I have to when with all this LLM
screw balless So, like
with all the LLM screwiness,
I end up doing it in passes
cuz I like I end up porting some stuff
with LLMs, but then also I receive so
many patches from contributors that
introduce LLM written jank. So like
for this 5C refactor, I had to take a
while to even get like the code into the
files that they like each piece of code
should live in what files and get the
file structure set up reasonably. That
took a while and then I had to like
delete a bunch of stuff that obviously
shouldn't even exist.
And then I had to move around. Then from
there be it became clear after that
without all the garbage in the way that
a few things were in the wrong spot.
And then you have to go through and get
like semi-automated, cut a bunch of
fluff and compactify some stuff.
And there are a bunch of like easy
refactor techniques for that. And then
it becomes obvious that stuff is still
in the wrong spot. And you know, maybe
after five passes, we you get to where I
am now where I can actually go line by
line.
And still sometimes there are like 100
line chunks that need bigger changes,
but I'm at least going through for the
most part line by line and cleaning
stuff up.
It's really obnoxious.
Hello, Jess. We are cleaning up
the puffer.
- 16 lines.
Small speed up. Very nice.
Yeah, this is better
for reduction.
Have a normalize
got sample
and again I don't care too too much.
Uh, I don't care too too much about this
Um, I'd say there's some very minor
speed increases, Jess,
but mostly it's shortening code and
moving stuff around.
Like there's nothing that has made a
noticeable difference in the overall
train time, even though you get like
very small improvements in um in kernel
profiles.
more distractions.
Um I mean the goal I the advice that I
give to new people if you read some of
my articles on X my like my advice for
programming in ML article is very good
as is the RL article like my like how to
get into RL.
It's pretty much just learning your
fundamentals, gaining practical
experience, and not getting distracted
by all the noise all around.
Okay.
Assuming
I don't care too too much about this
like this chunk here because this is
probably just going away in puffer six.
This is a decent chance at least.
We got to figure out why we can't do
this.
please be sure you do not link me a
shitty LLM algorithm.
Good thing in um it's confusing I know
being in um well learning at this time
but it's
it's really the case that like there are
certain fundamentals you need. Learning
those will make things easier. Don't get
distracted by people telling you you
don't need fundamentals.
Those people are dumb.
single rollout asynchronous.
That's already sketchy.
Uh, this doesn't matter at all.
like LMR. This is just like
LMRL for the purposes of doing nonLMRL
is effectively crap.
And it doesn't matter in our case
anyways, right?
That thing is somewhat interesting. I
guess
I will try that one thing.
But the rest of this, like you just,
like I said, you just linked me a random
LM algorithm.
Build us a live demo on Collab.
Oh, Collab, you mean where you run
Python demos?
This is pure CUD to see.
You can literally just download this
thing and run it locally and train
models on your laptop.
Oh, the RL paper.
I mean, that's also ridiculous, though,
right? Like, how am I supposed to
implement you a live demo like
fine-tuning a big LM on a collab GPU?
or post training, whatever the word is
these days, which is still training.
Omni reset with checkers.
I mean, it's nice in the sense that it's
like it's a really basic reset thing
that you can do. So, probably there's
you can do better if it does anything.
Oh yeah, I forgot that the collab has
the premium thingies, the premium like
whatevers,
you know. I still I don't do LLML
though, right? Like we kind of do
everything except LMRL.
Our whole stack is completely different,
right? Like Puffer is very heavily
optimized for small models. Um, we're
able to get up to 10,000x the
performance of stuff like SP3 out of the
box with Puffer
end to end CUT toC custom architecture
um heavy heavy kernel fusion stable
Bflat 16
many other optimizations
write the code. Well, I mean obviously
they are running their own algorithms.
They have experiments included.
Whether the code is any good is a
different story.
It is a little weird, isn't it?
Maybe not. We do know this is a slightly
unstable
Will 5C expose
overall logged values to M's natively?
What do you mean by that?
Something you train 50 million on very
limited hardware.
Okay, so 50 million parameters is bigger
than the biggest net that we typically
will train in puffer. Like a big net in
our case is something like 12 mil
parameters. Like we actually will solve
problems professionally routinely under
one mil parameters.
Um if you want to see like the scale of
what we're doing um as to give you a
sort of a yard stick we will very often
train on like over a pabyte of simulated
data. So, our models are tiny, but we
literally have more data than the
foundation or the was it the frontier
labs
for uh what we do.
Oh.
Uh,
you could [snorts] do that convert.
It's kind of a It would be kind of
gross.
I don't think we're going to really be
wanting to do a ton of manual curriculum
setup, though. We want to kind of like
automate it
pabyte of simulated data. So I mean you
build a simulator for the problem that
you're trying to solve.
You train a very small model directly
through interaction with that simulator.
We can train on up to like a trillion
interactions on one machine.
Get a kilobyte per interaction.
Filobyte times a terabyte, you get a
pedabyte.
Yeah. So you don't just like obviously
you can't build a simulator of
everything possible, right?
But the point is that there are very
wide range of problems for which you can
build a fast simulator
and a number of those like puffer kind
of just crushes
because of this level of data scale.
Obvious applications in control,
robotics,
uh games. We've done stuff in finance
and commerce. Longer term, I'm very
interested in applying this to
scientific sim.
Scientific sim tends to be less
interpretable though. So, we're really
trying to make sure that we have very
good stable performance across more
interpretable domains first, which
should be within the next year or so.
Yeah. So longer term, yes, my goal is to
get this into scientific simulation.
It's not going to be every single sim,
but it will be a ver a wide variety of
different sims.
Um, that is probably what I will be
doing once we have
stable consistent training on game ends.
Okay, I'm not going to bother
fussing with this cuz Finn is just
actively messing with this. So, sure, he
can add 50 lines of code. They're
annoying for a while.
Does this need to be here? Actually,
can I just like move this
up?
I can move this up, right?
Run an agent loop. I mean, you can burn
money if you want,
but uh
I mean, we can train our agents for like
pennies most of the time and dollars for
the bigger runs.
And Jess is right. You kind of just got
to do low-level dev around here.
Okay, I have lost complete. I don't even
know what the hell this conversation is.
Sure, whatever.
giant PO block. We'll give this the
initial pass and then I'll start looking
Oh, there's no pep if you don't have any
Python.
Uh, I literally did that, Jess. And um,
that was one of the cuts.
The point is, if you're only ever going
to free something when the program ends,
then you don't need to free it.
um, that
how is that an RL problem?
RL problems occur when you have some
sort of interaction
in like a multi-step process
where the interactions are sort of
fiddly and unintuitive
and there's an objective that you want
to obtain or maximize by virtue of
interaction.
device force. Oh, these
I don't even know if we need these, man.
I need to do a larger numerical study on
this.
But hey, Elliot, we're kind of just
cleaning up a whole bunch of crap at the
moment. We're making very small little
PF improvements at the same time, but
it's mostly just cleaning up a bunch of
crap.
It's a lot of like, why was this this
like so long again? Oh, okay. Cuz it's
half redundancy. Cool. Let's fix that.
Okay, so this is reusing the sampling
logic
which we should be
Why are you running on Windows instead
of Linux? I'm not. This is sshed into a
Linux box, my guy.
This is just an old desktop that still
had Windows on it.
So, this does have a local GPU,
so I can actually run demos
um in Linux through WSL.
So, that immediately is better than
having a MacBook. Okay, those are those
things are basically paper weights.
And I do have a Linux machine at my main
office setup. I'm in California for the
summer and I do not have uh like a nice
new machine here. This is just my old
desktop that I happen to still have
here. Works fine.
I'm sshed into my 5090 machine anyways
all the time.
Yeah, but working off of a laptop as
like your main setup, that's miserable.
That's absolutely miserable.
I used Mac OS for a few years and I hate
it.
Relatively recently I had to use one for
the summer as well and I hated it.
Like I don't know why. Like I just I'd
way rather just have a desktop.
Does Joseph read YouTube chat? Yes
I allocated a box to Finn. I don't know
if it was that one.
[ __ ] Intel. I swear. Never buying
another Intel chip.
That's actually a nice That's actually
kind of nice.
I have no idea what the hell's going on
in the chat, but whatever.
you should probably just use it for
logging like PF versus optimal, you
know,
You realize that we already have puffer
in Python
and like there is a version of like
literally The current public version 40
is a mix of CUDA with some C++ and a lot
of C and Python.
Like all you're going to end up is
getting something that's much slower and
longer than what we have now.
if you can model that as an interactive
process where you can iteratively refine
a solution or something then maybe
I I don't know enough about that area to
know if there's a reasonable way to set
that up as a like an interactive
optimization problem.
We actually do probably need to play
around with um
off pole correction again
because of async.
Uh, if it's going to cache, it's fine,
man. But why is it going to create a
path that's a cache path and a path
that's not a cache path just [ __ ]
randomly without testing?
Like, still add lots of little stupid
paths is the problem.
All right,
we'll let it spin for a little bit.
We probably won't have any anytime
shooting either, so it's fine.
Second read first. Yeah, that's kind of
what I figured.
Yeah.
The thing that's annoying is Twitter's
unfortunately also where like if you
just like every time you see um
if you just like do this not interested
like you will eventually get some cool
stuff there's like cool algo work
This is still nice though because like
this is actually I can see I can copy
this and I can stick this in the chat
for Jess.
This is one of the M's that we do care
about.
This is slightly faster in realistic
ranges.
It just does dumb stuff, man. It's like
I give it the precise ranges
uh to check for tests and it just like
picks some dumbass range.
Yeah, I know, Jess.
But it gives us a lower bound on um
how many weights you physically would
need to represent the policy.
very likely you can't get those weights
without training bigger,
but it's still interesting.
Like it probably has the architecture
and stuff as well.
I mean this is the big path right here,
right?
in some sense.
I don't know if there's like a multiple
thing power of two thing here.
Compact. Sure.
Use the restroom real quick. I'll be
right back.
Uh,
actually, I'll just waste I'll just wait
a second. We'll do a couple more things
and then I'll I'll take a quick break.
Just don't like how we immediately end
up in
in dent land.
Residual CNN.
Yeah.
thought. So, there is a dead branch
There.
just need to go through like in a very
disciplined way and compare flops and
memb bandwidth
and such of the operations.
wonders on that front not having
background.
that one's tough, Jess.
I I actually don't think a background in
ML would particularly help with that as
much as the systems does.
It's mostly just like comparing the
flops and the memory bandwidth of a
conve operation
to a linear layer with the same number
of params
and then figuring out why the heck these
things are so slow but are still giving
like good bang for your buck on
representational capacity.
Like presumably there are a bunch of
other things that we could do.
It's very difficult cuz the inductive
bias is hard to beat from the con.
There really should be a way to do it
though.
I mean, beat a con like globally is a
very hard thing.
I'm not going to trust this thing. I'm
just seeing if there's anything that's
free.
Yeah, that's fine. I'll be right back.
Let me use a restroom real quick.
We're actually almost all the way
through Algo, though, which is nice.
So, I've been live for three and a half
hours.
Man, I'm like losing I'm losing the
endurance here.
I know I should be able to do a six,
eight, whatever hour session. I guess I
am limiting myself to one coffee.
So,
kind of Jess.
I just really burnt myself on four.
I mean, that was a lot of work. I was
pushing that well beyond the point at
which I needed like I needed to take a
break.
I'm just trying to be very careful about
perf here as I'm cutting little things.
I think I'd probably have about another
hour, hour and a half on this file.
It's definitely improved.
it's like I could have written this in
high school almost like the language is
very familiar to me in some way.
I think you can only do that with one by
one comps.
I can't tell what he's doing with the um
the receptive field sizes.
this op this set of ops seems very weird
to me.
I'm not familiar with like more modern
comb architectures. I can't tell if it's
relying heavily on one by ones or not.
Um, if you can actually do
that block fusion operation in a set of
architectures that are useful, sure.
I think that you're pretty limited in
the
types of coms you can do that over,
though.
So, I I don't I honestly I can't tell,
Jess.
Yeah.
No, I mean it's cool. I don't know if
it's like
I mean the one good thing is this is
from
this is from May of 2024.
And it has some demonstration of actual
knowledge of past stuff.
Yeah,
I I would take a look
see if you can figure out with GPT or
whatever else. Figure out what the heck
block structure this is actually getting
applied to and whether it's like
restricting heavily the architecture you
can use and whether the restricted
subset makes any sense because I know
you can't do that depth fusion on
everything.
If it turns out that we can do it on the
subset of architectures we need, then
great.
Mhm.
I mean, comm stuff's important.
Architecture stuff's just really
like there's a lot a lot more that can
be done longer term. Jess,
I really I don't think that um
[sighs]
small nets are just not designed well
for the architect like modern uh
hardware architecture.
Right. But I don't understand the
architecture limitation of like is it
all one by one cons?
I mean, the funny thing is you don't
even like you can literally just
download you can just download Puffer 4
and it's already like That
That's not remotely optimized, but still
is ridiculous.
800s are actually slower than uh 5090s
for this type of work I'm doing here.
I'll let this figure out the regression
real quick. Be a nice patch if we can
get it to be um perf matched.
The thing is, John,
there are many ways to lie in academic
papers.
Some of the most lyingest of papers are
perfectly replicable.
No, actually we got the puff for AI
domain pretty cheap.
Nobody had it.
I was like looking around for like a
what do I do with the company? It's like
ah puffer. Let's see. Can I get the
domain? Oh yeah, perfect. Yay.
And then there's some domain squatter
bastards that keep trying to sell me the
uh theio for like 15 grand.
And I'm like, "No, [ __ ] you.
Wait, are we on B some 2 again? God damn
it.
Uh, this is not Grock not understanding.
This is me not understanding. What the
hell?
fully solve. Oh yeah, we have subsecond
breakout now.
Oh yeah, do star the puffer folks. It
does help me out a lot.
Yeah, I know. The dis GitHub broke a
whole bunch of stuff recently.
I think just the icon is broken, not the
link though.
They also they broke our star chart. I
don't know if you saw this. So, we used
to have this star chart here. They broke
that. It's really annoying. Yeah. So,
this link is still fine.
Breaking star charts a pain in the ass.
I'm going to have to fix that at some
point.
A R compact that saves 3x the calls.
I'm in group Muan.
Are you sure
you have a compact muon?
I don't
you can't really save 3x calls.
I did make one major improvement to Muan
earlier though.
Um I mean you should know SIMD as a
concept. Yes.
Particularly if you're touching GPU
anything.
The funny thing is like
you can kind of just write brain deadad
like 70s or well really like you can
write brain dead C99
and be a 1000x faster than basically all
modern software.
So,
Oh, and we actually we did end up
shorter.
Okay,
this is nice.
I just have to set up a I need to take
the time to set up um better benchmark
on stuff.
So you don't spend more time launching
it than running it because the whole
bloody thing is cuda graphed.
So if you're timing launch overheads
without graphing, those aren't real
numbers.
If you're timing, if you're looking
though at like memory pressure from
extra launches, then Mass.
What part did you batch though? Did you
batch the Newton Scholes or like
the problem that like the thing that
makes it difficult, right, is that you
have Matt Moles in the hot path.
I I still don't know what you did though
exactly
norm fused
the block map
but that wasn't the bottleneck even at
um
like Muan is still a very small slice of
training or should be unless I'm timing
wrong.
I think you have to split out the mat
moles in
Muan from the mat moles and the rest of
everything.
This is longer.
Much longer.
Man, I hate this colonel.
I really hate this colonel.
[ __ ] inlinined in like strings. my
ass.
Yeah. So, this is what we want it to
look like. It's very simple,
but it's kind of slow.
I'm honestly kind of comp like kind of
surprised that we just don't get this
from the compiler.
Isn't that weird? Actually, why the hell
does Why don't we get this from the
compiler?
Yeah, I don't have enough experience
with vectorization on this.
I see what it's doing. I just don't know
if there's like a alternative way to do
this that doesn't suck.
I don't have the uh
token speeds.
Few things at the end that were a little
bit iffy.
Still some improvements.
We are net negative here on lines and
that includes me adding additional
space.
I doubt that there were any meaningful
perf changes frankly.
Um, but we definitely we did clean up
quite a few meaningful things.
So I would say that that is
I'm just I'm committing this on this
side.
One in nanoconds per layer. Yeah.
Okay. Uh,
star
1,900 lines,
I'll probably make a couple small
additional changes, but I think overall
code quality much better today.
Much better.
All right, cool. I'm going to call it
here, folks. I got to get some food. Um,
what was this? This ended up being a 5
hour optimization stream or 5 hour
refactor stream. That's not bad.
I mean, if we consider I'm going to
consider that's like 90% done with the
algo file, though.
I've already put quite a bit of time
into Puffarel,
so presumably
a stream or two on that.
And there's not that much else that's
difficult that I need to play with. So I
this is a good chunk of work. This is
like a double digit fraction of the
remaining work done today, I would say,
for the release.
for everybody tuning in. If you're new
around here, I stream all sorts of
research, engineering, and so on and so
forth. Sometimes it's slow, sometimes
it's quick, sometimes it's educational,
sometimes it's research uh
breakthroughs.
And check out all my stuff on puffer.ai.
Start the GitHub. It's all open source.
Download it, train some models in a
ridiculously short amount of time at
home. Uh, join Discord if you want to
get involved and follow me on X for more
RL content.
Oh yeah, constellation super pretty. You
can play with all our experiment data
here.